head over to the best song ever.com and
purchase our new hit together again it
is a cover of smokey Mike in the god
king that's Jeremy boring and Michael
nolles and with your help we will smash
our way onto the Billboard charts I'm a
firm believer that an effective anti-war
movement has to be conservative because
when you look at the things people fight
for the things that motivate people to
enlist it's God country and family and
when the left is anti-war the way they
discuss it is God country and family are
stupid and you were an idiot for
fighting for those things and what
conservatives can say is those things
are valuable those things are good you
are a brave and good person who was
manipulated by Liars who don't care
about those things and were using you to
profit well I I I do think you're half
right Sheamus what I often hear from
better than usual better than usual from
when the left talks about anti-war there
are there are people I know I've had
conversations with and I'll make sure I
carve out respect for them but typically
it's this country uh this war is an
affront to to family and faith and and
and and stability in the economy for the
other country America sucks we hate
America America should be funding these
yeah a lot of this is not for profit a
lot of this is not for strategic
American goals I don't think these
people care about America these people
literally go to the Bohemian Grove and
do mock child sacrifices they literally
do Spirit cooking where they take bodily
fluids and try to summon demons they
literally go to private islands where
they hurt little babies and children in
unspeakable ways that we can't even
mention here on this particular freaking
broadcast these are evil Sinister human
beings that I truly do believe are are
are worshiping a larger outside entity a
satanic evil entity it sounds reductive
to say that but if you look at
everything they do it doesn't add up
until you put in the kind of spiritual
aspect to this they have been hijacked
they are not real Souls they are
individuals serving the greater
evil ask a very very quick question of
everybody okay uh Sheamus have you ever
been arrested oh man why got ask asked
me that here yes you haven't okay uh
Tucker have you ever been arrested I've
been taken into custody twice Charlie no
no okay uh have you ever been detained
no ever stopped and questioned uh in
Israel yeah okay uh that means and and
we and Ian you you've only ever been
detained yeah my buddy had weed in the
car that means for everyone here on the
stage you have served oh I we know
you've been arrested seven times for
journalism okay this means AR rested on
the way here that everyone here has has
done more time in any context than
anyone on the Epstein Client List for
the Epstein Client List it's like the
liberal economic order man it's the
least worst world order shout out to
Owen Shroyer for making that point but
but this is the issue that brings people
together and I want to kind of change
this conversation a little bit because
if you look at Left Right Center uh
everyone agrees hey uh what they were
doing for for decades with the FBI
covering up child abuse when Witnesses
and and people came to them and said hey
this is happening police officers judges
prosecutors politicians celebrities
media all played a part in it Megan
McCain said that literally everyone in
Washington knew what was going on
everyone was afraid of Jeffrey Epstein
this is this is something that will
bring everyone together and make people
understand hey uh the system is rotten
it's corrupted and it can't be fixed
until we deal with this one single issue
we've we've not only have heard these
stories of Epstein the Lolita Express
Madison cawthorne made some uh some
allegations Madison cauthorne was right
was right cuz we all saw as much as you
didn't want to that video out of the
Senate was The Heart Building hearing
room floor which was uh very disturbing
and I do hope they decontaminate that
building I mean that sincerely I mean he
should be arrested what he did was worse
than what 99.9% of people on January 6th
did and he should be arrested and putal
100 well I don't not beating a police
officer there's a couple people that did
but yeah well it is a desecration of the
space I mean most January 6th people
I've interviewed a lot of them as you
have and they're all I mean they were
there because they believe in the system
because they all had pocket
constitutions they thought it was real
and they were so shocked to see their
election stolen which obviously it was
and that they marched on the capital but
they were there to uphold the system and
some did it imperfectly and some got out
of hand of course but this guy is there
to degrade it to defile it on purpose
like there's no reason to do that in a
hearing room post it on the internet
like let's let's make this distinction
here as it pertains to January 6 there
were people who were that's bad you
should you should be held criminally
responsible if you're attacking cops I
agree with you Charlie there were people
there who were let in by the cops but
knew that something violent was
happening but more importantly I have
spoken with many people who showed up an
hour after any violence to cleared
cleared roads no Gates doors wide open
with cops smiling welcomed them in and
took selfies and those people I've met
two of them they're going to prison for
18 months and they said I shut up an
hour later it's a clear sidewalk we
walked up there are people Milling about
cops open the door we shrugging we we
walk inside for a few minutes we walk
out no idea anything ever happened next
thing we know the feds are at our door
the the these are not people who even as
you described tuer these are people who
are just there to see Trump speak and
happen to be in the wrong place at the
wrong time so how about no on that I
mean when is some honestly I mean I
don't you don't want to put anyone in
Jeopardy but like until people say we're
just not playing along with this anymore
obviously Congress isn't going to help
you know the problem it we talked before
about religion Christianity is like the
battlefield of the culture war and you
were talking about demonism and Satanism
creep into the culture in a lot of ways
I think one of the problems with
Christianity is that it encourages
people to be subservient to a church and
then therefore subconsciously they
become subserviant to a government like
why aren't they saying no well a man has
as many Masters as he does vices and the
reality is you're a slave to something
and if you choose to be a slave to God
as opposed to the government you will be
the most difficult possible man to
conquer but it's the way they Define God
you got to be aware that they're not God
he told us who he was I think and I
think Ian uh agree I but but but I don't
I don't disagree with Ian's point but I
think it would have to be refined in
that there are people who masquerade
pretend or don't truly understand and
would use Faith to manipulate others I
mean we see this in government
especially when Democrats claim to be
the real Christians but then say the
church is in favor of say abortion or
something like that yeah and I'm
obviously I'm speaking from a a
thoroughly Protestant perspective but I
don't see my reading of Christianity
just like the text does not at all
indicate loyalty to a church it
indicates fty to God yes and and so I
first of all it's not incompatible with
being a citizen at all um I think
Christians make the best citizens
actually and you can absolutely support
your government and support your God but
if it comes down to it if your
government is actively opposing God you
really do have to make a choice between
those two masters and and I'll make a
quick point Sorry Charlie I'll make a
quick point and Shout out our good
friend Bill Mah because it's a point
I've made frequently that whether bill
acknowledges or not as an atheist his
moral framework is built on
judeo-christian values this country was
founded he say that now he doesn't but
it but it's a fact Tom Holland wrote the
book called Dominion where he's an
atheist secularist who said that we all
have a Christian inheritance whether you
like it or not that's absolutely right
absolutely Bill Maher believes in free
speech he believes in innocent till
proven guilt all Christian values
Christian values and you know I uh uh
wanted to explore years ago why the
founding fathers decided upon these
amendments to the to the Constitution
and the framework as it was and you
learn a lot about how the Bible
influenced their views of what is just
and moral and so so just to
it at the surface reading you might say
oh you know Christians aren't supposed
to fight back against tyranny Exodus one
The Midwives to the Hebrews they
disobeyed the order of pharoh and they
said throw all the babies in the river
they said no we're not going to do that
and God said dealt well with them it
says in Exodus 1 Daniel 6 Daniel
disobeyed the order says you can't pray
anymore he says nope I'm going to keep
praying and he opened up the window and
prayed proudly and it ended up in the
lines then in Acts it says you obey God
not man so look throughout Christianity
we have seen honestly one of the most
successful the most successful movements
against tyranny are when Christians are
brought to a Breaking Point Christians
can be very agreeable and then as soon
as that snaps Disobedience to tyrants is
obedience to God I want to shout out
Sheamus real quick when he said you
would be the most difficult man to
conquer and this is exactly why I think
there is such a a a tremendous push
against anything that is related to
Christianity because these are people
who follow God who obey God and you need
someone to be Holden to a man because a
man can change the rules at any moment
that's right yeah well and so you guys I
know you mentioned you're coming at it
from a Protestant perspective I'm the
resident Catholic here so I have a
different perspective uh on the church
but I I will say part of the reason I
appreciate you so much and the things
that you've said on air is because even
though you're an Episcopalian you're
somehow like the most Catholic
commentator on air I find the things
that you say about like economic Justice
and also social conservatism tend to
line up very closely with the the
political values that I have uh as a
Catholic uh but I would say that of
course as Christians we should be good
citizens and Obey Civil Authorities when
they are not asking us to do something
evil but as soon as you're commanded to
do something evil you have to resist
that yeah the scriptures are very clear
about that you obey God and the church
tradition is is very clear about that
Tucker you made some very interesting
comments recently that has been uh going
viral all over social media when you
were specifically talking about um UFOs
and you you were specifically talking
about something that is hard to kind of
really understand here I was wondering
what's your kind of take on all of this
cuz I I see this as a spiritual war do
you see this as a spiritual war what
what are your kind of core belief
systems when it comes to addressing the
larger evils of the system well I you
know as I so often do I spoke
incompletely I didn't fully explain
myself um in the clip that you referring
to which like eight people have sent me
in Outrage that I basically said there
are things that I know that I won't say
which of course is not exactly right I
don't know I mean I can't prove it and I
really do try to like say things that I
really believe are true and are provably
so um and so that's kind of my hesitance
if I had facts I would I would say them
it's my personal belief based on a fair
amount of evidence that they're not
aliens they've always been here um and I
and I do think it's spiritual that's
that's my view and and again it's not
provable but based on on the evidence I
think I'm absolutely well the military
has been working in this realm for a
very long time they have been also
trying to to weaponize it there's also a
lot of crazy experiments that they did
with DMT hooking people up essentially
to dmti IVs having people go off into
the spiritual realm so there there there
if if you're not paying attention you
don't understand that there's a larger
kind of energetic uh frequency and
battle happening but can I say one thing
if the US government has in fact had
contact Direct contact with these beings
whatever they are I've already told you
what I think they are and has entered
into some sort of agreement with them
which is which is the claim of of
informed people um I would say whether
they're right or wrong I can't say
conclusively
if that is true I mean it's a very very
very heavy thing a lot of people say
interdimensional beings I want to ask
are are angels and demons or how would
you describe these these beings you know
I these are again I'm getting into the
realm of conjecture so I just want to
say that flat out entity but one thing I
know for a dead certain fact having seen
it is that um there is good and evil
that we are being acted upon at all
times and I think every person can feel
that in himself I mean there are moments
when you are moved to do things that are
much better than you actually are and
that are also more evil and destructive
than you actually are you are subject to
forces from outside yourself that is
absolutely true now we can argue about
what they are but every person in the
room if he's reflective will tell you
yes I know what you're talking about and
so there are forces that are not human
that do exist in a spiritual realm of
some kind that we cannot see and that
when you think about it sort of make you
think we live in an an Farm being right
and that's just that is real
and there's many artists also talking
about how essentially what they do and
their greatest works of art is usually
done through channeling of course and
and there is an aspect by the
way not that good yet um every by the
way every artist will tell you that
every artist that that something
happened that they're they're they're
not themselves that they just were were
doing their art and then something just
no but and it's not just Visual Arts
it's it's every creative act brings you
closer to something outside the human
realm and you can feel it whether it's
woodworking or writing or painting a
painting or writing an opera or writing
a rap song or whatever anything that is
true and beautiful or anything that is
dark and destructive is almost certainly
a product of forces acting upon you and
you can feel it God created us to
participate in Creation with him to
participate in his creativity and make
things that's right and since everyone
here is cool I'll say this um with the
respect to demons and spiritual forces
there's a a priest who lay asid towards
the end of his career he's relatively
controversial but he was an exorcist by
the name of Malakai Martin and one thing
he said about exorcism cases is that in
films you see all of these over-the-top
portrayals of head spinning and inv
vomiting and he said when it comes to
things like vomiting and all of these
these uh Supernatural visual indicators
of possession that those are the cases
that are the most mild because the
Soul's trying to fight back and with
forms of perfect possession the most
dangerous forms of possession you can't
tell when you look at the person because
they're perfectly content with the evil
thing they're doing and then you look at
the way people in DC act you look at the
way our political leaders act and you go
is it that much of a stretch to say some
of people and this is not some crazy
Outsider belief Jesus performs exorcisms
in the Bible like this is not something
thatr does it make you wonder that no
doctor has ever been able to explain
where exactly schizophrenia comes from
and that we cannot treat it we can
suppress it but we cannot treat it and
there's no kind of Baseline for it at
all there science has not schizophenia
so like what is that is the other thing
one of because and that's because in my
view is a you know 28y year old
cartoonist who knows basically nothing
about the world but if I would be so
bold as to speculate on this I think
part of that is the problem with
psychology is it doesn't take into
account that the human person is a body
Soul composite and that you are not just
chemical reactions happening at the
level of the brain in a series of
tangled up pathologies that produce
certain behaviors and states of
Consciousness you have a soul there is a
spiritual component to you that can be
acted on by outside spiritual forces
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 P.M
and become a member over at timcast.net